This lesson is all about code design.
When presented with the exact
same problem, two different
programmers will most likely come up
with two very different solutions.
Both work, but
how do you know which one is best?
Or is one better?
Is it just a matter of opinion?
What makes good code?
So how can we take all the tools you've
learned about, things like methods,
classes and inheritance, and
combine them in the best possible way?
Learning the syntax to define
a class is only the beginning.
In this lesson, we'll discuss
when you should define a class.
You'll learn about different strategies
for structuring applications,
with the goal of making our
code as flexible as possible